- No matter how small you start,
start something that matters.
Begin it.
You have to have vision.
I mean, it's Biblical,
where there is no vision,
people perish.
You know, if you have a dream,
never forget, you knock
on a door of opportunity,
that it is work who answers.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today, we're going to learn
from high-performance expert,
Brendon Burchard, and my take on his
Top 10 Rules for Success, Volume Two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening,
if something really resonates with you,
if there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put it in quotes so that other people
can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's most likely to stick
with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(swishing)
(powerful music)
- Believe in your ability
to figure things out.
I think that is the
ultimate belief in life,
that, you know what?
I believe that I can
figure out how things work
and I believe that I can get better.
That fundamental structure in our mind
it says, "I believe in those two things."
That, "I can figure things out.
"And I can get better."
enables us for lifelong
improvement and growth.
But without 'em, good luck.
'Cause if you take on a task
that you don't know how to do,
you say, well, I don't know how to do that
so I quit.
If you want to be like somebody
who you see as a role model,
but you don't believe in yourself,
you say, "Oh, I'm not like that."
So you quit.
So without belief as
the underlying element
of your own mindset,
there's no ability to grow.
There's no ability to go anywhere.
You have to look at this next
stage of your life and say,
"I believe I can figure it out."
If you have a great dream
and you don't have any clue
how to figure it out.
You still go, "I believe
I can figure it out."
Which allows you to get up,
and get to work on Monday,
and start working towards it.
If you don't believe
you can figure it out,
you don't have any, what
psychologists call expectancy,
or even agency.
And so you won't begin the journey.
But once you believe that
you can figure it out
and you can do it, then you'll begin.
So always believe in your
ability to figure things out.
And the first way you should
not compare yourself to others,
is in terms of, especially
today, their fans,
their fame, their
followership, their audience.
Never do that.
In my industry, that's
very, very popular to do
and it's ruined a lot of people's lives
who don't ever rise up to serve,
because they think they're
not popular enough.
It's like you write your first book,
and you don't have as
many sales as other people
and you think, "Oh, well,
I don't have the audience."
Or you go to someone's
fan page and you see,
"Oh, my gosh, look at their followership,
"look at how many Instagram
followers they have,
"how many Twitter followers they have."
And because you see them so big,
you think, "Oh, I could never be that."
so you don't even begin.
And a lot of people do that.
They say, "Well, I'm not that big."
So they never start.
But as I always say, no
matter how small you start,
start something that matters.
Begin it.
If I began my career looking at my heroes,
looking at a Wayne Dyer or Tony Robbins
or Marianne Williamson, a Deepak Chopra,
a Jim Rohn, back in the day,
or looking at people like Og Mandinos
who'd sold millions of books,
or even the famous books that you saw,
millions and millions
and millions of copies.
If I gauge myself to that and thought
that was the expectation,
I would never begin.
So you can't expect to start
out with tons of people.
Some people say to me all the time,
"Well, Brendon, it's so easy for you,
"'cause you got millions of
people on your email list
"and you have millions
of people on Facebook,
"and tens of millions on You Tube."
I say, "It doesn't make
it any harder for me."
I still show up and shoot this video.
And the reason I have the
followers and the fans
and the audience is because I showed up
and I started when there
was only one dude, 10 dudes,
hundred dudes, a thousand
dudes watching us.
My first seminar that I ever
did, we only have 22 people
in the room.
And now we fill up
seminars nine times a year,
often from people from 46
countries around the world
fly in paying thousands
of dollars a ticket.
And what did I do?
I started with 22 people in a room,
and most of those people didn't even pay.
And every time the guy
walked in with water,
I counted him as one of those 22.
(laughs) I had no followership.
It's never about how big you
start, it's that you start.
And you get big by staying at it.
Because what people do is they
put out their first video,
they write their first book,
they try their first thing online
and nobody follows, nobody
watches and they quit.
They get disappointed.
And where there's disappointment,
there was too high
of an expectation on
achievement versus learning,
versus process, versus beginning.
What you want to do is
never be disappointed.
And the way that you're never disappointed
is you understand every
single step counts,
every single step is learning,
every single step gets you going.
Greater leaders envision
a compelling and different
and vibrant future than what is here.
They have an alternative clear view
of what the world could be like tomorrow
than it is today.
They have a shared purpose.
They believe that they and others
would be compelled by
interested, inspired by,
and want to work towards.
And that's a big deal.
And you always read about
it in leadership, right?
You have to have vision.
I mean, it's biblical,
where there is no vision,
people perish.
We know the power of having that vision.
So you have to sit down,
though, and actually do it.
The reason we say envision,
versus just have a vision,
is you have to sit, it's
a practice of envisioning,
"What should tomorrow
look like for my team?
be like for my business,
"for my organization?"
What should tomorrow
be like for your life.
And not just tomorrow, a
long-term mindset and view,
the dream, that magnificent obsession,
that bold desire, the moon
shot goals and purposes
and missions of life, the bigger picture.
That's envisioning a different
reality in the future
than we experience today.
And that's what everybody
gets excited about
in leadership.
Where there's no vision,
there's no leadership.
Where there's no vision, people perish.
So we have to envision.
We always have to continually sit down
and envision, "Where are we?
"Where can we be going?"
It's an active process.
If you just had a vision one
time and you forget about it,
it's not going to help you
accomplish the influence
or the impact you want in your lifetime,
or in those that you need.
My whole career has been,
in some way or another,
a struggle against my own
doubts all along the way.
As much as people say,
"Gosh, you're so confident.
"You're the high performance
guy and everything else."
And I'm like, "Yeah, but it
doesn't mean I don't struggle."
Matter of fact, I probably
put myself in situations
where I must be challenged,
and I must struggle,
more than any normal sane person.
(laughs) I'm constantly
pushing myself all the time,
because I evaluate struggle
as something to be honored.
It used to be struggle was something
that was truly honored by people.
They thought that was
something that built character.
They thought that that was
something that was good.
And now we've got to be such
a convenient driven society
that's into ease and
so much just, I think,
an unbelievable level of
engage, I'm sorry, entitlement,
but people don't think
they have to earn it.
And I was like, wait, if you have a dream,
never forget, if you knock
on a door of opportunity
that it is work who answers.
(laughs) It takes a lot of work
to achieve your bigger dreams,
to become the best you who you can be,
to serve more, to create more,
to contribute at the highest level.
Man, it's a lot of work.
So I need you to do your work
before you respond to the world.
It's the number one thing
I'm always telling people
in High Performance Academy
and all my other training sessions is
if you are constantly
waking up in the morning
and all you do is just reply to everybody,
and you're replying to their text,
you're replying to their needs,
you're replying to their emails,
all of a sudden, the day is ripped away
and you find yourself
out of your own routine.
But if you set up your morning to win,
or you set up blocks of time to win,
as we'll talk about.
And you do that first, do your work first,
it's easier to stay disciplined.
If you're saying, "You know what?
"This year I want to,
in the next two months,
I want to be more healthy.
Great.
Get your health stuff out
of the way in the morning.
Create your shake, do your workout,
create a healthy lunch to take to work,
and you're off and going to a good start.
But if you wait for the
remainder of the day,
for discipline to strike,
it never will.
I know you all have big goals, big dreams,
big aspirations, just like I do.
You've got ambitions to
become an amazing person,
to build your career, to
create, contribute, to give,
to be an awesome human being.
But all of that is impossible
without great habits set up.
If you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way
that will keep you on
track, then you'll fall off.
And having new goals without new habits
is kind of like having a
new car without wheels.
The habits are the wheels.
They're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals.
So you got to have good habits.
But the challenge for most
people isn't that knowledge.
I mean, you know you
need to have good habits.
It's you can't keep
the habit going, right?
Have you ever started it the new year,
your'e going to get healthier,
and you start that habit of working out
more on a more regular
basis and then it goes away.
Or you say, "I'm going to be
more kind and more patient
"and more awesome to
my partner, my lover."
And you start being nice
for two or three days.
And then on the fourth day you're a jerk.
(laughs) And you're like, "What happened?"
"I said I was going to be nice to her."
It's that you didn't set
up the most important thing
you needed to maintain a habit.
So what's the biggest secret I've learned
in almost 20 years in this field?
It's so simple, but most
people don't have it.
It's called trigger moments.
You have to set up trigger
moments to activate your habits.
What do I mean by that?
Well, let's say you want
to become a better person.
You want to become more
kind, more patient,
more loving with people.
Now you can just that intention
or write that down in your
vision, or in your journal,
or set up on a vision board
that you look at once in awhile.
But in day-to-day life, it's not enough.
You need things to trigger
you, to remind you,
to be that particular
kind of person, right?
It's almost like if
you have a little angel
speaking in your ear all day
long to tell you what to do
and how to be, you'd
obviously become better.
Well, that makes sense.
Well, let's use that idea.
Let's use that idea by setting
up alarms on our phones
that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do.
This is going to be so
basic you're going to laugh.
And then I'll also tell you
how I've literally talked
to just to Fortunte 50 CEOs,
and they said it was the one
thing that changed their life
the most dramatically.
So let's start with this.
Let's say I have a goal in mind.
Let's say you want to become more present
and calm throughout the day.
Again you could write
that down on a journal.
"I'm going to be more present at calm."
You could meditate in the morning saying,
"Today, I'm going to be
more present and calm."
You could start out with good intentions.
But those fall apart
without a trigger moment
set up throughout the
day to remind you that.
So what if you did this?
What if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the
day, with a label that said,
"Close your eyes,
"take 10 deep breaths in,
remind yourself to be calm."
So let's say you're
going through your day.
It's crazy, right?
It's 10 a.m. and all of a sudden, bing,
your phone goes off, you look down,
and it says, "Close your eyes,
"Take 10 deep breaths."
And then again it happens at two o'clock,
and again it happens at six p.m.
and again it happens at eight p.m.
What's going to happen?
You always look at your phone, don't you?
It's going to go throughout
the day, you didn't forget.
And the funniest thing is,
I've had so many people do this worldwide.
We're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people
I've taught to this,
hundreds of thousands.
And they tell me all the time,
"That changed everything."
And you'll think once you set it up
that the next day you'll forget about it.
No, that alarm will go off,
you forgot you set the dang alarm.
There it goes off in your face,
and you're like, "All right.
"I'm trying to be calmer and more present.
"Close my eyes, take 10 deep
breathes, reground myself,
"here were go."
You can't do it once a day.
You have to have moments
throughout the day
that trigger you to
enact the new behavior.
I know this makes sense to you.
But it's a challenge for a lot of people,
'cause they never set those things up.
So what if you did it with an alarm?
For example, for me, on
the opposite spectrum,
I don't want to just be
calmer and more present,
I want more energy throughout the day.
So here's what I do.
One of my big trigger moments is
every time my butt hits a chair.
I don't care if I'm on a plane, or I was,
where we're shooting here,
I wrote a lot of my books here.
I wrote the Motivation Manifesto here.
I wrote The Charge here.
And if I'm going to write,
my butt hits the chair.
I grab my phone, I open the timer,
and I set 50 minutes.
Now at 50 minutes, the timer goes buzzzzz,
it starts buzzin' and I
look at that and I go,
"Oh, that's my trigger to get energy."
So I stand up, I go get some water.
I take a glass of water, drink it down,
I do some stretches,
and I do some exercise,
just really briefly, or I'll
go for a walk, whatever it is,
but I'll do something that usually takes
just two to five minutes.
Then I'll sit back down,
I'll set that 50-minute alarm
and I'll work.
And what that does is every
50 minutes it triggers me
to change how I'm physically moving,
it changes my attention,
so that throughout the day,
I'm continually refreshed.
So I never have that two,
three, four o'clock time
where I'm like, argh, you know?
Why?
Because I'm triggering my days
so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day.
Makes sense, right?
This could be as simple as,
let's say you want to be
healthier in your life.
Okay, let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way.
Let's say every time
you drop off the kids,
on the way back to the house,
you stop at the grocery store
and get some fresh produce.
That's just a trigger.
It's like, okay, did one
thing, drop kids off.
Now tied to that,
triggered from that action,
drop kids off, is go to health food store.
Or let's say you want to get
healthier in the morning.
One of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better
exercise program is this.
Set a trigger, you wake up in the morning,
your first action is to drink water.
Put your exercise shoes on.
Might get dressed if you
were naked, just saying.
So you get dressed,
(laughs) put your shoes on.
You go downstairs or you go to the gym
and that's the trigger.
You woke up, you do these actions.
Nothing interrupts those
actions, that's the action.
And you have to have those setup.
One of my other favorite
trigger moments to set up
is door frame triggers.
Well, you remember that.
When you walk into a new room
to have a psychological
trigger go off in your mind,
then you associated with that doorframe.
So let me give you an example.
If I walk into my house at night,
if I've been working all day,
and I'm going to walk in,
I'm going to see my lady,
I have it so whenever I walk
through the doors of my house,
three words repeat off
immediately in my mind,
because I've done it so
many times consciously.
I went to the door, I
said the three words,
said the three words.
And I did this so many times that now
when I walk through a door,
my mind automatically
triggers those three words.
And I remember to be those three words.
So what words would you
love to have describe you
as a person that you
would be happy if that was
how people described you?
What would those words be?
Have those and now set
them up in your life.
I teach executives do this as well.
I have them have a doorframe trigger
when they walk into their
office in the morning.
Soon as they walk through that doorframe,
they have boom, three
words go through their mind
about how they want to
be perceived as a leader.
I have them set up another door frame.
Every time they walk into a meeting,
into the conference room,
when they walk through the
doors of the conference room,
they have another three words
that trigger off for them.
And it just reminds them how to be.
So these aren't big crazy things.
A lot of people think
they have to completely change their life.
What would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger
moments and associations.
That when you see something, you do this.
That when this action is
taken, then that happens.
That when you have the opportunity
to set up alarms on your
phone, you set 'em up,
so that you're interrupted
in your every day life
to remind yourself to stick to the habits,
to stick to the intention.
You do that enough on a continual basis,
you'll find yourself in so many ways
completely rejuvenated.
And I promise, you'll stick
to your habits even more.
And once you do that you
know that everything changes.
People don't believe in themselves.
It's not that there hasn't been evidence
that they shouldn't believe in themselves.
They've had some wins,
they've had some goals
that came true.
They made the magic happen,
but they never integrated the win.
They never had a good thing happen
and they sat there at
the end of the night,
thinking about that
good thing that happened
and allowing it to come into their heart,
allowing whatever they did to
give themselves credit for it,
permission to feel good about it and say,
"You know what?
"I did this today.
"It went well today.
"That worked today."
And to integrate that win,
integrate that success,
integrate that moment, into
their heart, into their identity
as a human being.
What happens is most of us, we
knock off the checklist and,
"Did it, did it, did it,
did it, did it, did it."
And five years later, after all these,
"Did it, did it, did it, made
it happen, made it happen,
"crushed it, crushed it, crushed it."
And five years later, we feel
the same about ourselves,
the same level of confidence,
the same level of belief
in ourselves, because we
didn't allow those things
to enter our psyche, enter
our spirit as strength.
We didn't.
We had momentum, externally,
but we didn't have any
momentum internally,
building our character and our strength.
We never achieved that
sense of pride or ownership
of what we did.
We didn't own it that we did
it, so we never go stronger.
At the end of the day,
just sit down at the
end of the day and go,
"What worked today?
"What did I do today?
"What little thing
"should I allow myself a
little bit of credit for?
"What did I say that was nice or kind?
"What did I send away that I got done?
"What did I finish?
"What goal did I move a little closer to?"
And just at the end of the
day to allow that to come in.
This isn't about just pepping ourselves up
and saying, "I'm awesome,
I'm awesome, I'm awesome."
With no evidence.
I'm saying, you know,
you got some momentum,
integrate that now.
Own that.
You did the work today.
You fought the good fight.
You finished the day.
You're still alive.
You know what you need to go do tomorrow.
Integrate that success,
give yourself that credit.
You'll develop that strength
of spirit that's so important.
What would I have to
do in social situations
to be able to develop some confidence.
What would what I need to do
to develop a deeper competency,
skillset, talent, ability,
in this new area that will
make me an all around stronger,
more competent and capable person.
I think we should focus on the plan
to develop your strengths much more
than just stopping some
of the inadequacies
or the worries.
Those will always be there.
If you don't have them, the game is over.
If I ever get to the point
where I'm backstage and
I'm about to go out onstage
and perform for thousands of people
who've paid thousands
of dollars to see me,
who came from 40 plus
countries to be in the room.
If I don't have any anxiety to that,
some performance anxiety,
that's going to tell me
that's probably the day I
should turn it in, quit, retire,
'cause it means I don't care enough about.
I want to experience some anxiety.
I want to have a little stress.
We know from high performance studies
that a little bit of
stress can give that edge
in performance, as long as it's managed.
As long as it's utilized as
a tool, to pay attention,
to focus, to execute,
versus as an excuse to stop.
So how have you been using anxiety?
As a performance enhancement tool?
Or an excuse to stop?
The world's highest
performers use it as a tool.
They get an edge from it.
And they say, okay, I'm nervous.
But that tells me I'm in the
game, I better pay attention.
And they also develop plans
to develop themselves.
To strengthen themselves
in all their areas,
emotionally, socially, financially,
physically, spiritually
so that those anxieties
start to diminish as they become more.
Stop prioritizing easy.
A lot of people when they
look at their to-do list
of the day, they just start
working towards the easy things,
knocking off the easy things.
They think, "That's going
to get me some momentum,
"it'll get me into the day,
"or I'll feel like I'm succeeding."
And the reality is it's
making them less likely
to actually do the things that count.
And how do you know this?
How do you if you're guilty of that?
You'll know is if your day feels like
there's a lot of busy work,
but there's an absence
of your life's work.
You know what I mean?
If you don't feel like you're
activities during the day
are really creating to your vitality,
to the contributions you
want to make with the world,
to doing activities, and
tasks that you really enjoy.
Whose fault is that?
Is it the man's?
Is it the government?
No, (laughs) it's like
you're setting up your day.
You could choose what to do with it.
Maybe you need to look at doing things
that would support you, your health,
your vibrance and your
joy, your real growth
and contribution in a
more significant way.
If you feel like there's always busy work,
but it's not your life's work,
you probably prioritize
things at a larger level
maybe incorrectly for you.
Now I don't know this.
I can't gauge it.
I mean, I'm just talking to you through
here now, as I look at you listen to me,
all I can do is encourage
you to just look and say,
"How have I been prioritizing?
"Have I had a structure?
"Have I had a framework?
"Have I had ideas about what's
important to me in the world?
And I always run my
decision-making through those,
because if you haven't set that up,
this is the time to do that for yourself.
- Just because there's
something that's easy to do,
does not mean it must be done today.
What I would rather you to do is say,
"I am going to prioritize things today
"that will make significant
steps forward in my life."
These are, I just say,
the opposite of stop,
or sorry, prioritizing easy
is to prioritize progress,
things that actually move the
needle of your life forward,
things that actually contribute
in ways that you find meaningful
and significant and fulfilling.
And you know you deserve that.
But sometimes you get caught up, right?
Now you've just been caught
up in everybdoy elses's
hot mess.
And your life best became a hot mess.
It's not because you are,
it's that you're just doing
the easy things to please people,
because that's easy,
"Ah, I'm going to please
some people today."
But what we need you to do is say,
"What would significantly move
me towards my dreams today?
"What three things must happen today
"that would be real movement forward?"
Not like little checklists.
Our whole world has gotten so addicted
to little tiny checklists,
but they're not doing anything meaningful.
They're not checking off,
"I'm living my life."
(laughs)
So I want you to get back into,
"What would really progress me today?"
Stop prioritizing easy,
start prioritizing progress,
things that matter.
I want you to take on
something hard every day.
You do that, you'll start to find yourself
getting a little more confident,
a little bit more momentum,
a little bit more into
that space where you feel
like you're doing things
you were meant to do.
And the last big one, you
knew I was going to go there.
Love.
You know, you already know
the thing about love yourself.
And maybe in some ways
you've never allowed that.
You've never noticed the beautiful things
you've done in your life.
So you never allowed
yourself to love yourself.
But at some point, you've got to recognize
that there's a love that's beyond you,
beyond me, and beyond your actions,
and that love is whatever
brought us here alive today.
Some would say it's God's
will and God's love.
Some people it's the
randomness of the universe.
Some people it's nature,
some people it's whatever.
But there is something way beyond us.
And there's a way to access that
and a way to honor that.
And the way to honor that is
recognize that you are unique
about seven billion people, no
one is like you specifically.
And at least take that
as a moment of saying,
"Okay, I'm meant to live my uniqueness.
"I'm supposed to love the things
that make me odd and weird.
"I'm supposed to love the
things that make me strong.
"I was made this way,
"so let me honor what's good about that.
"And what's not good about
that, let me work on that.
"Let me set a schedule
to get better at that
"so that I can not only
honor what I've been given,
"but I can give something
back, too, by getting better."
And that aspect of doing that
that brings in so much joy
and so much strength in our life is love,
loving ourselves, loving the process,
and of course, the greatest
way to believe it ourselves
is to love other people that
they become so grateful for us
that they give us some of that feedback,
that there's so much
appreciation and love and joy
in the moment with others
that you can't help but
just feel that vibe,
that there's an emotional contagion.
When other people around
you are feeling loved
and cared for and excited about life,
it's hard not to rub
off on ya' a little bit.
And you start saying, "You know what?
"Life isn't so bad.
"And you know what?
"I deserve to feel good
here right now, too."
And, you know what?
You start getting some
momentums, some wins,
you integrate those wins,
you get some feedback to get better.
And all of a sudden you start
to believe in yourself again.
All of a sudden you start
to live the charged life.
- Thank you guys so much
for watching this video.
I really, really, hope you enjoyed it.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next top ten,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what
was your favorite message
from this video.
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately
apply somehow in your life
or in your business.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout to Sean
from Video Influencers.
Sean, thank you so much for
meeting up in Palm Springs,
doing that awesome
interview on your channel
about my book, Your One Word,
and then you posting it to your channel
as well as to your Twitter.
I really, really appreciate
the support, man,
and I'm glad that you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swishing)
- So my question is,
when was the last time
you just gave yourself a few moments,
free away from playing on the phone,
free away from the Internet,
just to sit down by yourself
to visualize and daydream
about your dreams, about the
activities involved in that,
about how you would struggle through,
about what it would feel
like to be victorious,
all of it, the whole thing,
the messy party, the ugly part.
What would you say to
yourself when it gets hard?
That's what you need to do,
to truly actualize a dream.
We got to begin with
seeing it and sensing it,
the good, the bad, the easy,
the difficult and the victory.
Every week on a Sunday, I
think about all the goals
of the week I just had, and all the goals
of the week I have coming up,
and I literally measure myself.
I'm like, hey, how did I do?
On a scale of one to 10
last week, how'd I do?
Eight, I did good, six, not
so good, four, I sucked.
(laughs) Okay?
And I rate myself every single Sunday.
I think it's really important
that you take a look at
your goals on a weekly basis
and rate how was your performance?
How did you do?
Not just did you accomplish all of them,
because, you know what?
Life comes up, your kid
gets sick, you get tired,
some big emergency
happens in the business.
Something will always come
up that will prevent us
from achieving every goal that
we have every single week.
But its' a good idea to
say, "Where did I mess up?
"Where did I quit?
"Where did I stop?"
Not to berate yourself
or be hard on yourself,
just to acknowledge where you're at.
Because if you're not
looking at your goals
on a weekly basis, at least.
I mean, what are the odds you
keeping working towards them?
Just 'cause they're a
to-do list in your calendar
doesn't mean you're going
to keep going after them.
We all have a level of
competence, I guess,
ceiling if you will,
that we hit a top level
in which we can take
ourselves only so far.
And then we need someone from
the outside to look at it
and say, "Ooh, hey, kid, you
need to adjust this, man.
"Try doing that.
"Oh, have you thought of this?
"You know what?
"When you're doing this,
it's only this level,
"it needs to be this level."
IF you get somebody, somebody.
And everyone says,
"Well, Brendon, I don't have any coaches?"
Really?
Well, how many have you asked?
You always tell me, "I
don't have any coaches."
Okay, great, how many did you ask?
Are we failing in the asking?
Or are we failing in
the never approaching?
Where is it?
Most people don't have
coaches in their life,
'cause they never sought them out.
They say, "I wish I had that."
But they never actually sat down and say,
"Hey, you know, I'm
starting something here.
"And you seem to have
competence in this area.
"Can we make an arrangement?
"Can I hire you as a coach?
"Can I pay you as a coach?
"Could we do something together?"
I mean, I started getting
coaching informally
from dozens of people in
my industry just by asking.
And now today I coach so many
people I can't even count.
It's just like crazy.
But I think that's what
we have to start figuring
is who's going to coach you?
And if you don't have a
list of 10 or 12 people
who you think you could
mentor you or advise you,
or coach you, then you're
kind of grasping at hope
and fate that maybe someday
a coach will land on you.
But, you know, I think you're
going to have to go out,
just like every other area of success
and work a little harder,
a little more focused
in that area to have success there.
Same with coaching, you
got to go get a coach.
(swishing)